but i hate nine to fives
nine to fives are legitimately the
biggest scam
ever ran in the universe listen to my
advice
please 925 jobs they are the biggest
scams in the world
welcome to fake guru friday have we got
an episode for you
today i am your host and look i know
some of you guys have been saying hey
that's a that's a that's a pretty lame
lambo back there steven looks pretty
fake hey you know what
you were right i'm sorry guys to lie to
you uh i didn't have a lambo this whole
time because i was waiting
for my real lambo to come in guys listen
i want to inspire all of you
if you dream it you can do it okay
like napoleon hill says you make it your
vision if you just focus on the orange
lamborghini
it can be a reality hey that's right
ladies and gentlemen you can trust me
now because i have an orange lambo
in my studio now don't ask me how it got
in there i won't answer
but uh welcome back how are you welcome
to the end of the week
you made it through congratulations
today we are reacting something that
really
got under my skin you guys know me
pretty calm guy but
tore me up a little bit let's go to this
this screen the main screen come on guys
because we are reacting probably the
dumbest thing i've ever seen
and you know what it's a recurring
occurrence with the gurus
have you ever heard this before hey
college is a waste of time what are you
going to school you getting educated doc
don't you know that's a scam
hey that's that's total scam you ever
heard of
steve jobs ever heard uh
mark zuckerberg didn't even go to
college bro didn't even hey you want to
be mark zuckerberg why are you even in
school what are you going to princeton
loser so let's uh let's react okay
the main video we are reacting to is
this okay
why i hate nine to five jobs by
the swag academy
that's right ladies and gentlemen we're
learning about school from the swag
academy you don't see the rest of the
title but it also says
nine to five jobs and the educational
systems he's hitting us with both
barrels
at once okay we're getting nine to five
jobs are a scam and
the educational system i can't wait to
learn more but
before we go further we say i'm not
trying to single this guy out
a lot of these idiot mentors
coaches so-called millionaires from
their courses
also are promoting this idea okay
they're promoting a false
narrative and we're addressing it today
here's tai lopez in a video called
should you drop out of college let's
hear what he has to say
i do find it interesting that when you
look at the most successful people in
the world
they dropped out of college a lot of
them oh and
there it is okay but they continue this
narrative successful people billionaires
millionaires they drop out of college
here's rich dad robert kiyosaki saying
the exact same thing
most of my friends dropped out of school
and they're they're multi-millionaires
let me make that mike a little closer to
your face robert greatest entrepreneurs
in the world they never finished school
you know a guy named um steven job steve
jobs
walt disney uh zuckerberg and the list
gets pretty short after that guys
i'm just setting you guys up with what
everyone says okay they say look most
successful people don't go to college
hey tai lopez says it robert kiyosaki
says it
they can't be wrong can they they're
millionaires after all
and that brings us back to the main
video of today
mr swag academy because he just takes
the argument that these guys are making
and takes it to the next level so i'm
going to address all of these guys at
once
let's pop into this thing all right and
i've never really expressed my true
thoughts on it on camera
because i know it's a controversial you
know subject
and i know society teaches you a whole
different you know viewpoint on life
but i hate nine to fives nine to fives
are legitimately the biggest scam
ever ran in the universe and i don't
understand why people
are just content and can't grasp that
concept
the biggest scam in the universe
are you joking listen there's bitcoin
scams
okay there's there's there's tai lopez
seminars how can this be the biggest
night hey nine to fives
that's a scam where people tell you
they're gonna pay you and then they pay
you that's a scam
but please mr swag go on i i didn't mean
to interrupt you there
look at every single thing you do in
life as a scam
except on nine to five and i'm here to
debunk that and before i get into that
if you don't know who i am already my
name is swaggy city i'm 25 years old
swaggy c okay 25 years old
he's not going to mention this but he
also sells a 4x course so that's why he
said like you look at everything else in
your life of scam you're saying i'm a
scammer for telling you how to do trade
forex
but you go and work your nine-to-five
job you loser but let's hear who he is
sorry
i live in downtown los angeles i'm a
multi-millionaire all that extra stuff
cool great whatever
you know i'm just like a millionaire
multi-millionaire something oh it's over
companies
no double deal like guys it's like
whatever nah it's actually a pretty
pretty big deal
the reason you you dropped that where'd
you make your money though he says he
made it from trading
quite frankly i don't believe it now
we're going to make a separate video
exposing
these 4x little fraudsters but i'm not
going to talk about his forex trading
performance here i'm just going to let
you know
that um i'm suspicious okay but let's go
ahead
i felt it was necessary to give you guys
some background on me that i'm not just
some
random weird kid with a bunch of
subscribers you know trying to give you
guys advice no
yes you are i feel like i am verified
and solidified
i like to talk about this i have
millions i have a beautiful wife
says who listen hey i've got millions
you've got millions
just don't ask for them i mean i hope
you guys don't ask
me for all i can show really is that on
millions of dollars of debt but
multi-millionaire just don't because i
wish people understood you can just say
this stuff
and it doesn't have to be true uh but
anyway go ahead go ahead sorry sorry i
keep interrupting
i have a nice dog
[Music]
what does having a dog have to do with
anything
all right hey i've got a dog too you
know that
if the dog is all it takes to be a
professional on the internet now we got
this
sit barney show the people how good you
are show them the empire that i built
oh he's just scratching himself never
mind i wasn't that good of a look for
for my uh empire actually
listen to my advice please and
have an open mind okay nine two five
jobs
and some of you guys may think that oh
this is obvious i'm still going to say
it anyway
like if you don't know who i am i rent a
lot they are the biggest scams in the
world they don't care about you
they can fire you at any point it
literally
makes you stagnant and content with life
i feel like this is someone who really
doesn't understand jobs talking about
their opinion about jobs you know what i
mean like that's like really the vibe
i'm getting
like for me i've worked 195 no job in my
life and i was
miserable with those two months at
jcpenney wondering
you're ranting about nine to five jobs
but the one job you had
is two months at jcpenney well of course
you hate jobs
of course you ate nine to fives i'd hate
it too if i were you if all you've ever
worked at is jcpenney of course you
think
yeah jcpenney probably is a scam i'm i'm
no friend of jc or penny
how can anybody think this is okay like
you go to college for four years with no
guarantee that you'll ever be successful
or have a good job
then you work an entry-level job
somewhere else for 10 years hoping to
climb the ladder
and hoping to grab that imaginary brass
ring to
get promoted or get a higher salary it's
all
fake yeah what would you rather him do
huh what should everyone do hold on hold
on
let's all collectively quit our jobs
okay now that we've all done that
what are we gonna do now swaggy see um
maybe we should take your forex course
maybe everyone in the world should stop
working and uh all these nine to five
scams because it's
fake and we should all become day
traders of forex
hey that's a good idea everybody can
just trade currencies
like him be a multi-millionaire trading
currencies dude this is
this is really how you live your life if
monday is the worst day of your life
you're doing something wrong
if friday is the best time in your life
you're doing something wrong
what's wrong with enjoying your weekend
your days off i don't understand this is
like a workaholic insisting everyone has
to be workaholics
like a lot of times i would literally
ask my videographer austin or my wife
bailey what day is it
a winter okay cool friday okay cool i
don't know because i'm too busy
grinding and working and chasing okay
don't pretend like that's some kind of
brag hey if you join my course
you won't know what day it is hell you
won't even know what century it is guys
you're gonna i'm gonna be right or wrong
plus or minus 100 years that's how much
i love my job like how's that a brag
i mean i'm so sick of these guys
peddling lies look this is the truth
look if you get a high school diploma uh
on average you're gonna make 40k
if you get a bachelor's degree on
average you're gonna make 64k
if you get a master's degree on average
you just make more
you make more when you're educated uh
that's a fact whether these people want
to admit it or not
but do they have any stats to back up
their course success stories
no they just have a bunch of anecdote
testimonial they have no
they have no charts like this and look
my point is not to hate on college
dropouts i have a whole show about real
jobs
that people get uh without a college
degree you can go look that up
but my point is is that if your dream is
thinking that you're gonna drop out of
college
and make more money i got some bad news
for you and this is the
pernicious myth that these guys are
selling and i want to get to it finally
which is that rich people do not go to
college guys
successful people they don't need
college because i know my audience a lot
of you guys are highly motivated
you're highly ambitious and for those of
you who are
i don't think money is the answer but if
you think that you you have to be
ultra rich you better go to college and
these people are telling you the exact
wrong thing college scam everything else
not a scam
open up your mind okay you'll be a lot
farther there's no reason why more
millionaires and billionaires
dropped out of college and chased their
dreams than those who graduated
wait what that's not true i guarantee
you that's not true we'll look it up if
we have to
you think more millionaires and
billionaires dropped out of college than
went to college
it's exactly the tai lopez robert
kiyosaki argument like oh hey a bunch of
these guys dropped out
i looked it up that's a statistic
there's more millionaires and
billionaires who dropped out of college
than those who finished college okay and
this
is where this is the point of the entire
video because this video has
73 000 uh views 6 000
i i know you guys can't see that 6 000
likes
and all the comments are overwhelmingly
positive when people basically say yeah
college is a scam
nine to fives are a scam they're being
lied to by this guy who's saying
it's statistics he's looked it up guys i
looked it up too
and this is the actual truth guys when
you look up the numbers it's the exact
opposite of what this guy says this
is a chart showing uh how many people
did a survey of the most powerful people
in the world whether they went to
college
or not the blue dark blue is whether you
went to an elite school
light blue is college gray is uh no
college you're a dropout
as you can see if you're a 30 million or
you're worth 30 million dollars or more
there's a 20 chance you dropped out of
college
the rest of it you either went to you
had about a 50 chance of going to a
college uh 34 chance of going to like an
elite school like harvard forbes
billionaire
hey does that number increase is he
right that you're more likely to drop
out of college no of course not
total lie meaning ty lopez is wrong
robert kiyosaki is of course
wrong this guy the swag academy is wrong
about school
of course 11 of them dropped out that's
such a low number and notice it dropped
from 30 millionaires meaning
if you want to make more money it's even
more important to go to a school
and even more important to go to an
elite school as you can see the elite
school has jumped up and i'm
again i'm not hating you guys i went to
texas a m dude not exactly an ivy
okay so i'm not i'm not trying to flex
on anybody i have nothing to flex about
world economic forum attendees same
thing
all of it same thing especially when you
go to forbes most powerful men
hey 85 percent of them elite schools
15 regular college my point is the more
ambitious you are he's trying to make it
seem like if you're ambitious
that's the kind of people who should
drop out actually it's the opposite look
the more ambitious you
are the more you need to go to school to
achieve whatever ambitions
you want the less ambitious you are look
if you're lazy
if you don't have any direction if all
you're going to study is basket weaving
in school
and you and you don't want to you know
achieve something you don't have
direction
sure i understand maybe college isn't
right for you it's too expensive i get
it
there are a lot of not smart people not
using college correctly they're getting
in hundreds of thousands of dollars in
debt and it's a bad decision for those
people
but for this guy to go on and say hey if
you're driven you know if you have if
if you're a hustler if you want to be
rich go get go drop out of school
this guy is an idiot sorry to say sorry
to say
it's just it is what it is this is the
worst advice you could be taking
and the worst part about this is he's
positioning himself as some expert you
need to listen to
but you know he says you shouldn't
listen to get this
and i need you guys to realize stop
taking advice from your parents
unless they are in a situation you want
to be when you grow up
you know my guys your parents are dumb
hey parents you know grew up poor
a lot of people i knew no they were
never really good with money
why would you listen to their advice
clearly it didn't work for them and i'm
sorry to hurt
you he said like hey your parents are
broke dude they don't understand
anything
that listen so don't listen to your
parents guys don't listen to your
parents but who should we listen to
whose advice
should we listen to listen to my advice
please
so so okay let me get this straight
college is a scam
nine to fives are a scam swag academy
not a scam
your parents scam uh you shouldn't
listen to those guys
because they're broke they're broken
dumb dude honestly they're dumb
swaggy c though 25 year old
multi-millionaire forex trader
this is the guy you guys should be
listening to this is hey
this is who you should be taking your
advice from i can't explain to you how
infuriating it is
to watch this guy literally pedal lies
and then call them statistics it's
hilarious he goes he goes
i looked it up it's a statistic where's
the statistic
uh because i'll tell you where mine is
uh jonathan why
heiner rindemann but i know guys these
guys went to college they're big doo doo
heads who probably didn't achieve
anything guys
meanwhile we're going up against swaggy
c how dare we
how did oh that's tai lopez wrong guy
and like the thing is look
if you're gonna put in chat well
actually college is kind of a scam
look there's dumb things about college
it's too expensive
you know there's all sorts of problems
but don't tell me that if you want to
make more money in your life and you're
super ambitious
drop out you're gonna tell me that it's
just
i just can't believe it's a problem
anybody can
pose as a millionaire anyone can pretend
to have this empire like i said guys i'm
a millionaire you guys should listen to
me
after all didn't you see my lambo at the
beginning of this i mean i hope you guys
know that's the real reason i put it
there
is uh to establish credibility here you
guys know i'm successful don't you see
my lambo
forget your parents listen to me guys
and i'm telling you
look you don't need college to have a
very happy life
you don't i don't think riches are the
end all be all
but for those of you entrepreneurs who
are saying hustle hustle quit your nine
to five if you're gonna quit your nine
to five it's even more important for you
to have a college degree
i'm sorry to say it it just days so
that's it
sorry guys you know me i i rant a lot uh
like swaggy c so i hope you enjoyed this
video this episode of fake guru fridays
i'm just so sick of this crap
these guys are spitting out because
it's couldn't be further from the truth
and watching them get
applause applause for all their fans who
like are like yeah this is so true man
it's just not and you know i just wanted
to counter that misinformation
that's getting out there hope you guys
enjoyed i hope you had a laugh at the
swaggy sea
because we'll be talking more about them
and more about forex because that's the
biggest bubble
we need to talk about is all these fake
forex traders so we'll talk about that
soon
but uh anyways that's all for now and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you